Oh, that's gas. Sorry.
(titters)
That'd be an amazing intro!
(both laugh)
Poof!
I won't— I won't put my hands
on the little controls there. That's fine.
That's all good.
This is Barry Lewis.
Cook with a YouTube channel.
Hey Tom. I am.
Yeah, we're gonna make
some strange ice creams.
Okay, I said strange.
Well, I mean...
we could've gone really strange.
But I'm pretty sensible.
I don't know.
The brief that
I gave to Barry was like...
"Weird, but possibly still good."
Yeah! I'm intrigued by
what you've done, flavour-wise.
We've come up with two, right?
Yeah.
You've only seen the ingredients
I've brought over there.
I've only seen
the ingredients you've brought.
And I feel like you've been
slightly more traditional than I have.
I mean, I was gonna go
to the deep, dark archives
of things that people send me sometimes.
But I thought, no.
We're gonna try and make
four ice creams.
Yes.
And we're gonna try and taste
four ice creams.
And we'll see how it goes.
Do you wanna get the base mix?
Yes.
What's in the base mix, by the way?
Well, it's— Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll follow you with this camera.
It's just a basic... base mix.
There's loads of different ways
of doing a base mix. This one's sort of...
just milk, cream, and sugar.
Yep.
So normally, if you wanted
a vanilla ice cream...
Yeah?
...you would have some
vanilla extract in there too.
But it's basically
a chilled bowl, where...
it's gonna hit that freezer bowl
that we put in there,
and it's gonna start churning
straight away,
because if we just put it in
at room temperature,
then it's gotta start
working really hard again,
and so you're kind of
losing that momentum.
Yeah. And we've only got
two ice cream bowls,
so we gotta get
two batches of ice cream
out of both of these.
Alright.
Yeah, so the freezer bowl
that's been in overnight...
I'm leaving in there til the last minute.
It's gotta be two— Yeah, alright.
So it's gonna churn,
and then as soon as we're done,
maybe we can make
the weirder-flavour one.
It'll be fine. It'll be fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, let's— let's start with the
slightly more normal one.
Yeah, get that done.
What've you got for me first?
What've we got? Those all look
very conventional to me.
What've you got?
Yep. So, yeah.
So, we've got some
white chocolate chunks, or chips.
And I've got some meringue nests.
I might sprinkle that in at the end,
'cause I feel like the moisture
in the mix might absorb it.
It's kind of like icing sugar.
Yes, that's going to make mushy meringue.
You wanna drop that in, just at the end.
A little bit of a [pinch] on there.
Some coconut,
and some marshmallow fluff.
Alright!
So the chocolate, the coconut,
and the marshmallow fluff's gonna go in
probably after about five minutes.
Wanna get it going first of all,
and I'm gonna start dropping that in there.
So, this is my idea called the Snowball.
This is the one where you've gone kinda...
fairly conventional, fairly sweet.
Yes!
Right.
♪ (bright acoustic music)
And then we mix that together.
Yeah.
There we go.
Alright.
Yeah, nice.
Ohh! (chuckles)
Oh yes.
Cool.
I may have gone a little bit weirder
on my first one.
Okay.
This— So—
I found out
from a Filipino friend of mine,
that cheddar cheese ice cream
is a thing in the Philippines.
Wow!
And it's also usually non-dairy,
and I don't know how they do that.
But it is this combination of sweet and salty,
and things like that.
Like, you can buy...
Unless I have been comprehensively hoaxed
by both a friend of mine and the Internet,
which I'm not ruling out...
Yeah, yeah.
Apologies to the Philippines
if that's happened.
There's no lies on the Internet.
It's all legit, right?
But assuming that,
cheddar cheese ice cream,
which kinda got salty, sweet...
Yeah, I see. You got the dairy
as well, and yeah okay.
So I was trying to work out,
how do I make that a bit more interesting?
So what I've got is,
Yorkshire-Filipino ice cream fusion.
...Right, okay!
You know how people in Yorkshire
make apple pie...
Right, yeah.
and then put a slice of cheddar cheese with it?
Apple and cheese?
And I've got—
Let me get some ingredients.
Okay.
Apple-pie-with-cheese ice cream.
(laughs)
Which is...
Sweet apples.
Yeah.
Medjool dates.
Oh nice!
Really deep caramel flavour in there.
Yeah-yeah-yeah.
A lot of vegans use that to make
a vegan version of Snickers for their caramel.
Yes, um...
Hobnobs as a base, biscuit base.
That will all be a traditional
apple pie ice cream, but also...
Some cheese.
Extra strong cheddar.
And the reason—
I don't want to take it over, but...
That combination, like...
Yeah.
I went to uni in Yorkshire.
I know what it tastes like.
That combination really works.
Okay.
And I— I genuinely think
this might work?
I don't actually like
cold cheese amazingly.
Ah, okay. Should've
found that out beforehand.
I'll still eat it.
The weird thing is, I like it melted.
It's so bizarre.
I don't know which it's gonna be then.
I think this is gonna be a sort of
a sharp undertone in it.
Yeah, I mean,
hopefully these other flavours...
Alright.
...will...
I've dropped you in it here. Sorry!
I mean, for mine,
I'm just gonna chuck it in.
But do you need to prep
any of these?
I need to chop some apples.
Yeah.
I mean, what might be nice,
if you've got a...
I might try sautéing the apple for a minute,
and if you've got a little bit of butter
and some heat...
Oh, yeah! Wow!
caramelise the apple.
We're going to town. Yeah, definitely.
Alright.
Yeah.
♪ (bright acoustic music)
There we go. Alright.
You putting some cheese in?
I'm putting some cheese in it.
I think— I am not—
'Cause it's too easy, isn't it?
It's too damn easy to just make
date and apple ice cream.
Alright, let's do that.
Here we go.
Nope. (giggles)
Agh.
Fine.
I don't want too much in here.
No, no, definitely. (laughs)
Oh, nice.
What?
(chuckles)
And I just pour?
Yeah.
How much, all of it?
About two-thirds, if that's—
Oh, the mixing thing is in it.
There we go. That's about right.
I'm-a just get this.
All the sweet, right.
In it goes.
That looks and smells really nice.
It's only the cheese
I'm worried about.
"Tear here."
(chuckles)
Let's crumble that in.
Up.
Okay, yes. 'Cause the hot—
I don't think we let the—
I don't think I let the apple
cool enough there.
Okay.
So that is not as firm, but...
We can get...
We can get it firm.
Yeah, yeah.
There. Actually I'll pop it in.
Yes.
So that goes on the top, in there.
What's your second one?
Marmite.
(both laugh uproariously)
Right, okay.
'Cause I think it's gonna taste amazing.
Sorry, I just— I just—
Right. I've got you with cheese.
You've got me with Marmite.
'Cause I'm generally
not a fan of Marmite.
It's not bad...
I like Twiglets, and I hate Marmite too.
You know the old ad slogan they had,
which is like, "You either love it or hate it"?
I'm indifferent to Marmite,
so we'll see.
I— No, this might work.
This is a thing I see with sugar as well.
It might actually be
a slightly sweetened yeast extract,
which is what it is, right?
So I like Twiglets, but
I don't like Marmite normally.
'Cause the intensity of it,
but it might dilute it.
I love the way, by the way,
that you just dropped that.
Like, Marmite, fine.
I was expecting a long discussion of...
"Marmite." Alright, fine.
I was gonna go for Marmite and mustard.
But I thought that might be
a little bit speckly and a bit too heaty.
And I'm hoping for
either like a marbling on the colour,
or maybe just a real...
Ooh...
It might just go the colour of Marmite.
It might go deep, dark or lightly brown.
It's quite thick stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
So we'll see what happens.
Yeah.
If I get a marbling, I think
that's gonna be almost gourmet.
♪ (soft rock)
Let's let that go.
Ah, I've got marbling.
There it is.
It's gonna be fairly soft.
That's okay.
Yeah.
We've established this.
Go for the sides.
There's the blob of Marmite.
Aww.
There we go, that's three.
Alright.
We're now going to kind of just push
some overdrive button, or something like that.
'Cause this is gonna require
a bit of backstory.
Okay.
So...
I did some filming with
Korean Englishman.
You know their channel?
Yes.
We did some lovely filming.
They gave me a little gift bag at the end of it,
which is very kind of them.
Oh wow.
I have not brought a gift bag for you.
Oh, okay. (laughs)
But what they gave me is
this lovely gochujang hot sauce.
Oh! I've got some of that
in the fridge.
But a paste.
Right, so.
I might actually use it,
'cause it's gonna be better than the...
Right, so...
What happened, I was like,
"That would work,"
'cause it's not
the kind of hot sauce I like.
It's got that sort of fermented note to it.
And I like sort of cayenne and
citrus-forward hot sauces.
Yeah, nice.
So it's kinda been sitting in my cupboard
for a couple months.
And it's also viciously hot.
Okay.
So we've only been using drips of it.
Yeah.
So I was like, "You know what I'll do?
I'll put some of that in, it'll temper that down."
Okay.
You can add strawberries to it.
'Cause strawberry gochujang is
a very common Korean thing.
Oh, is it really?
Yeah, you combine them, they work really well.
So I was like, "What I'll do is I'll get
that hot sauce, [with] strawberry jam."
That'll work. That'll be interesting.
Yeah, yeah.
So when I set out this morning, I...
For the first time, I looked at the label,
and it's all in Korean obviously.
Yeah.
And for the first time, thought I'll just check.
Are there any allergens or
any things in there?
"Keep refrigerated."
Okay.
Two months, that hot sauce
has not been refrigerated, so...
It could be really angry then!
Yeah— No, well...
Not wanting to poison you,
I have got some gochujang paste...
Oh nice.
But that's not spicy hot sauce.
That's just the paste, which is...
Yeah, yeah.
It's just fermented red pepper
and soybeans and...
Yeah, I think that's what I've got.
The first ingredients are
corn syrup and spirit vinegar.
This is very anglicised.
So you've got the real good stuff then(?)
No.
(laughs)
That's the best I could find
in the supermarket on the way here.
But, I also have...
What they gave you was...
crushed chile
and a little bit of habanero.
Wow!
We're not gonna go massive on this.
I'm not gonna go all the way in.
Okay.
But I'm gonna try and replicate
that hot sauce they gave me.
Yeah, okay!
And...
"Intense" strawberry jam!
Not your regular strawberry jam.
I don't know what the difference is.
Tents-in-a-cirus jam.
Yep. Yeah.
So that's my second plan.
Okay.
My second plan is strawberry-gochujang
hot sauce ice cream.
Gochujang paste.
Good lot of that in.
Okay.
There we go.
Wow, that looks really... vibrant.
Yeah, it does.
(both laugh)
Not sure that's a good word, but...
(giggles)
It looks so nice and innocent.
It bloody doesn't.
(laughs)
Lactose...
What was that— Oops.
But lactose acts as an anti-capsaicin.
Yes. Yeah.
So hopefully...
You could neutralise it
a little bit, yeah?
I mean, that's the plan.
Strawberry jam.
Uh, might regret this.
(wheezes)
Oh, wow!
Good wow?
Yeah!
I mean, like, that's hot.
That is burning hot.
But... as a hot sauce,
that's lovely.
Like, that's a sweet hot sauce.
Ohohoho, wow!
Ohh!
(huffs)
(laughs)
For the fourth ice cream
coming out, you know,
there wasn't much freezing power
left in this.
I think we might've— might've
got that about right.
Yeah.
One, two, three, four.
Yeah, that was the order, yeah?
Alright, first one?
First one.
This is the one with
perfectly normal ingredients in.
This was you being kind.
Oh, the Snowball.
But, I need to get my crushed meringues.
Yes, you do.
Can I spring for that?
Yeah, yeah. I'll— There we go.
That's a scoop of ice cream there.
Oh!
Agh!
(laughs)
Well, that...
that's going in the sink, and...
I'll get a different scoop of—
I missed the sink. Sorry, could you put
that ice cream actually in the sink?
Where?
Oh my gosh, yeah-yeah.
I aimed for the sink,
and I missed it.
There you go. You can see, I think,
some of the marshmallow swirl in there.
Want some?
If you could, yeah.
Get a bit of meringue
over the top of that. There we go.
This is something
I've dreamed about for years.
I've actually really
wanted to do this flavour.
Alright, this should be good.
Surely, this should be good.
Hopefully. Coconut, white chocolate.
Coconut, white chocolate, meringue...
Some people might not want the coconut.
...and marshmallow.
Coconut, white chocolate...
No, you've made good choices there.
You've made very good choices there.
That's nice.
Mhm.
Bit of a— Bit of a crunch
from the white chocolate chips.
Bit of a crunch from the meringue.
At first, I wasn't getting anything.
The coconut's gone through yet,
and the chips.
I want a bit of marshmallow.
I saw a bit— I saw of a piece of it.
Mhm.
Now... you've got a good flavour there.
You could sell that in ice cream shops.
People would love it.
Oh...!
"Tom & Barry's" is a thing, definitely.
(both laugh)
It's on!
"Ben & who?"
This one'll go back in the freezer.
That's a solid ice cream there.
Yeah. We'll spend the rest
of the night eating that.
This is the one
you were most nervous about.
So this is— I'll be honest,
the colour on this...
does not look great.
I was—
(loud pop)
Is it meant to do that?
I bought them specially for this video.
I assume—
It looks like a DeLorean actually.
So, this is the second one
we did with that ice cream maker.
So it was a little bit melty. That...
It was!
If this was just... Medjool dates,
apple, and biscuit crumbs...
this would be like the last one.
We know it'd taste good.
Yeah, it smelled outstanding.
But I have added cheddar cheese.
So...
Ooh, I like that consistency.
It's a little bit soft still.
I think that's the apple having its effect.
But...
Have you scooped ice cream before?
You look like a pro, that's amazing.
Nah. I'll take the compliment, but...
I know also that some of the
apple and date mix...
Well, the sort of apple-date-cheese mix
did glom together into blobs there.
Do you wanna— There we go.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, let's show that off.
That is— That looks promising.
It does!
If that didn't have the cheese in it,
I would have no—
I would be eating all of this.
It's just delicious stuff.
Gourmet. I love the way,
the scattering of the ingredients as well.
And I'm wondering if the dates are
gonna give it a caramel vibe maybe.
I hope so.
Let's find out, alright?
I did not know that
Barry didn't like cheese, by the way,
before this. This is the— There's a—
Yeah.
It's really weird.
If it's melted, like I said, love it.
Oh wow...!
Oh my gosh!
There is something
going on there, yeah.
Yes!
Hang on, let me make sure
I get some of the...
Oh, I definitely had some cheese.
Okay, right, okay.
For someone who doesn't like cheese...
There. You know what?
No, that's...
The dates and the apples
give it a texture,
and then I had a bit of the biscuit as well,
where you put it in towards the end.
So it hasn't fully dissolved in.
There is a sharp undertone to that
from the cheddar.
But I was worried that I over-cheddar'd it.
And I haven't.
I am declaring this
Filipino-Yorkshire ice cream,
despite not really being part of...
Even the Yorkshire part of that isn't—
There's not much of that in here.
But...
It's amazing!
And I love that consistency as well.
It's just perfect scoop on there as well.
There is enough crunch
from those biscuits.
The dates and apples clumped a little.
Yeah.
And there is just a slight, salty undertone.
It's like the same way
that salted caramel works.
Yeah, the sweet
and the savoury combined.
The sharp— That intensity
of that cheese.
I thought I was putting
too much cheese in.
I thought we were just gonna get
cheese ice cream here.
Yeah.
That's...
I really like that.
I'm not nervous about the hot sauce one.
I'm nervous about the Marmite one.
Yeah...
I don't think that's gonna be a great...
I'm hoping that it's...
gonna be subtle.
Here we go.
I think it's kind of settled.
Oh no! Oh no!
(giggles loudly)
That's, um...
(laughs)
That's some deep marbling in that(!)
That's not deep marbling.
That's a mistake!
It's a Marmite ice cube, isn't it?
Alright. Maybe...
Okay.
You know when you put the ice cream—
You know when you put
the Marmite in at the end?
Yeah.
And you're just like, "It'll marble through."
I'm not convinced it's done that.
I'll let you scoop this one.
Yeah, okay.
Ooh, it's firm.
Oh, the consistency on that's weird.
(giggles)
That's...
A Marmite hole at the bottom.
Okay. I hope it's not dispersed.
Something's...
Know what I mean? It's got like...
Yeah.
So the—
I mean, the colour's like—
The colour is definitely Marmite... what?
(both laugh in horror)
Oh no! Alright, alright.
In the interests of—
Can you just—
That's still my spoon. Let me—
Let me make sure I've got
a little of bit of that in as well.
Yeah, I feel like I'm gonna try...
Let's have a little bit of marbling in there.
Yeah. Gonna try a little bit
as it is.
As someone who's not really
much of a Marmite fan...
Oh yeah.
I'm not...
There is a slight shade change
compared to the base mix.
It has taken a bit of the colour.
Definitely. Definitely.
So let's try...
Some without the...?
Oh, this is gonna be a mistake.
Ooh.
No.
I can taste the Marmite, but...
Yeah, you can, you can.
No!
(wheezes)
Ooh, I feel like I'm eating toast!
I'm not getting toast off it.
I'll be honest with you, mate.
I'm gonna go a bit deeper with this.
I know, I have as well, and...
Ooh. I don't know if that's
gonna pick that up, but...
Like a leopard.
...No, that's...
Oof!
That's a mistake.
Ugh, no!
That gets worse as it goes on.
(giggles)
And I don't like Marmite normally,
but that's...
That's a new thing.
I think— I think
someone who knew about
molecular gastronomy and things
could make that work.
Yes.
I think there is a flavour path.
But that ain't it!
Yeah, I wonder if it
settled like that because...
when we put it in obviously,
it was that batch that wasn't fully...
and it went, "I'm going down to the bottom.
I'm Marmite. This is what I do."
Maybe...
No, I can't. I genuinely—
I was gonna give it one more try,
and my stomach and mouth
are both saying, "No."
"Just stay alive."
That's... That's deeply unpleasant.
Thank you for that.
Sorry, Tom.
I'll get you back in the next one.
Oh my gosh, yes... yes.
You need, like, safety gloves for this?
I can still taste the— Oh, that—
That gets worse!
How is that getting worse?!
I'm not eating it anymore!
(laughs)
I'm sorry.
(faucet turns on)
Ugh! I need to rinse my mouth out.
That's genuinely awful, Barry!
(laughs)
That's absolutely awful!
(softly) I can still taste Marmite.
Yeah.
I can still...
I think it's that, like, syrup—
Oh my gosh. I forgot about that.
(both laugh uproariously)
Oh yeah.
Alright, have you got the spoons?
Yes.
Do we need spoons or shovels or...?
(stammers)
Yeah.
I'm still confident about this.
I'm gonna be honest with you.
You might want to have
a glass of water on hand perhaps.
I mean, traditionally if it's hot sauce,
you're meant to have ice cream
with it to numb the heat.
Oh!
Right.
So this is one of the reasons
I thought this would work.
Amongst everything, other than...
You saw me briefly try
the hot sauce stuff, and it's like,
"This is a good hot sauce."
Yeah.
And one of things that's meant to numb,
or like, act against hot sauce,
is lactose.
Yeah, so milk and stuff.
Milk, ice cream, anything like this.
So... I am not...
unhappy with how this looks.
Come on. There we go.
I wonder how it smells.
'Cause when I was washing up earlier
with the habanero stuff...
My nostrils went up.
Mixture of strawberry and gochujang.
Like, that smells as you'd expect
from the ingredients.
Consistency looks good.
Oh my gosh.
What I'm worried about
is the chopped chile that's in there.
You can actually see flecks of
chile and habanero in there.
And I think that might be the error.
They're going like, "Yeah!"
It also hasn't set massively well.
That had the longest time
in the ice cream machine.
Yeah.
And it's not really solidified.
And I wonder if that's an effect
of the strawberry jam.
I think it could be.
The high sugar content in there...
the sugar will affect the
crystallisation for sure, but...
Alright.
I mean, to be fair, we have done well
to get four ice creams today.
Yeah. With two ice cream makers.
I mean, that looks angry.
I'm not gonna lie.
It does, it does. Um...
I was entirely confident about this flavour
until about five seconds ago.
I mean how—
But this is—
I'm the one who did it,
so I'm gonna get a big scoop of this.
You don't have to.
Okay.
I'm the one who signed up for this.
I might start with a small one.
Alright, let's see.
Wohoho...
There's something going on there.
Feel like I could do
an aftershave advert.
Whew.
Ooh!
That starts really nicely.
Yes.
The strawberry, the gochujang,
the spice definitely works.
Ooh.
(titters)
And then you swallow the ice cream,
and all the lactose is gone,
and the heat stays behind.
And I had a small speck.
But I mean...
It feels like you're on
a roller coaster of pain,
going "Wahey!"
and then it comes back up and...
You know what?
I...
I'm gonna stand behind that.
That is strawberry...
Oh yeah. I got the jam then,
with the gochujang.
Yeah.
That's nice.
I'm... (laughs)
I was expecting
much worse than that.
And we get...
I mean, I'm getting heat.
(sighs) I don't think I—
But I chopped a whole habanero
into that thing!
Yeah.
Let's make sure I get
some of the chile flakes in here.
That's...
It's definitely there.
I feel like the sugar in the base mix
has helped to smooth it.
And the jam as well.
That's definitely...
Oh.
That's caught in the back of my throat.
Yep.
Yep, but...
It's manageable. (titters)
If you squint a bit!
If you wanna make this,
if you wanna make it,
I actually recommend that
as a flavour.
Strawberry gochujang
is a known thing, that works.
Add a load of heat in there.
That works.
Yes.
The ice cream manages that,
gives you a really interesting flavour profile.
Chop up the chiles a lot,
a lot smaller than that.
Like, food process the chiles
into tiny, tiny things,
because...
I just got one of those caught
in the back of my throat.
Yeah. The heat is
right there now, like a speck.
And it's...
Yeah.
That's hot.
(giggles) I feel like
I could de-ice a car!
It's not hot until
all the ice cream melts away.
Yeah.
(chuckles)
There's nothing there to help you.
I'll tell you what. I would...
I mean, maybe I'm just
blowing my own trumpet here, but...
I would go for that
in an ice cream shop.
I think if I ordered that
at an ice cream shop,
and that's what I got,
I think it'd be like, tick.
"This is what I paid for."
You expect that,
and you want a bit of heat.
And like I said, once that milky,
ice creamy profile goes,
you're left with the heat then,
and it's like, "Raaah!", but then...
Which is kinda the wrong way around,
because the solution to that is
more ice cream!
(both laugh)
It works though. I mean...
I love the jam running through it.
That's not bad.
I think that's got a real nice...
it's just those little habanero things.
But then I think that maintains
of what it's supposed to be,
as like a fiery, sweet mess,
of goodness.
Which I loved!
Thank you, Barry!
Yeah, we're awesome!
I don't know what
we're gonna call that.
I was assuming
that was gonna be a disaster,
[Caption+ by JS*
https://caption.plus]
and we were gonna title it like,
"Hot sauce ice cream is an
abomination toward God and man!"
But, uh.
Is Tom & Barry's the new thing?